(slapping noise)
(swinging hinge noise)
(upbeat music)
(bell rings)
- Do I put it upside
down to dip just the...
- [Voiceover} yeah
- will it fall off?
- Dip only the fish part into the sauce.
- Okay, and I put the
whole thing into my mouth?
- Oh, this feels so sexual already.
- Ummm
- It's delicious, no matter what you do.
- (laughs)
- Zero percent different
from how I usually eat sushi.
- It's fun to eat things
with your hands though.
- And putting the fish right on my tongue,
kind of enhance the taste experience,
because it was straight to the taste buds.
- When you put it in rice first,
the rice bits are gonna fall down,
and so you'll just be picking
them out of the soy sauce.
- Dip control is important
in sushi. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
- How are you supposed to eat ginger,
is there a certain way?
- [Voiceover] No
- Like upside down? (laughter)